birth control allowed hose to be hosed
then the provider the hose don't take
the providers they pick the chats then
no fault to Boris allowed the host to
leave then the government undid them
leaving and then social media made girls
that are sixes think their nines and
tens and deserve nines and tens and
think they're too good for the guy
that's on their level and then they
marry the guy that's on their level and
then they're thinking about these guys
and they're like damn I wish I could
have had those guys and so what they do
is they break up their home because they
think they can do better and they can't
but then what happens at the end of the
day there's no consequence because if
you simps who bail them out class
dismissed